[Musique]
bonjour à tous le journal de la
rédaction de tv soixante dix huit pour
un point sur l'actualité locale et nous
sommes le mardi et 19 novembre les
titres de cette édition
le déplacement de la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur à guyancourt
frydrych vidal était ce matin à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines déplacement sur le thème de la
précarité et dix jours après qu'un
étudiant se soit immolé par le feu à
lyon hier c'est le haut-commissaire aux
retraites jean paul delevoye qui a été
dans les yvelines à vélizy-villacoublay
il a assisté à un débat public afin
d'expliquer le projet de réforme et
recueillir aussi les interrogations et
critiques des citoyens présents
enfin des lectures contre
l'antisémitisme auprès des élèves dans
les lycées le théâtre montansier de
versailles a lancé l'initiative cette
année dans une vingtaine
d'établissements du département ce matin
étape au lycée dumont-d'urville à
mortain à suivre aussi nous parlerons de
la grogne actuelle des personnels
soignants dans les hôpitaux contre le
manque de moyens et d'effectifs et puis
focus sur une association qui oeuvre
dans les yvelines ces bouchons d'amour
[Musique]
dans un contexte tendu dix jours après
l'immolation d'un étudiant a lieu à lyon
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
frédéric vidal s'est rendu ce matin à
lui vs q la thématique de ce déplacement
la précarité étudiante mickaël millero
et patrick jacques de dixmude étaient
sur place
la précarité étudiante au centre de la
visite de frédéric vidal à l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
s'est rendue dans l'agora une épicerie
sociale et solidaire installé à
l'intérieur de la faculté est géré par
des étudiants évidemment le rôle
épicerie et le rôle solidaire est très
important mais je crois qu est ce qu il
faut pas oublier c'est le mot social
c'est aussi un endroit où les étudiants
qui parfois parce qu'ils viennent de
quitter leur famille et se retrouve seul
et bien peuvent échanger peuvent
partager les choses on néglige trop
souvent la question de la solitude et la
précarité ça enferme aussi dans la
solitude l'épicerie ouverte depuis
septembre 2018 à guyancourt propose des
produits alimentaires et d'hygiène
les tarifs entre 10 et 20% du prix du
marché on voit que la ministre ait
touché par par ce qui se passe par ces
actions là qu'elle les soutient et donc
ça pourrait encore faim comment dire
favoriser le développement aussi
d'autres d'autres tags oreilles
hier et puis d'autres structures en
règle générale pour aider les étudiants
la ministre est également venu pour
annoncer officiellement la création d'un
numéro d'urgence
objectif aider les jeunes à mieux
connaître les aides j'ai encore de
constater si ce qu'on me dit c'est la
difficulté pour un jeune qui se trouve
dans une situation de précarité peu
importe qu'elle soit soudaine ou
qu'elles soient aux constantes et c'est
donc mettre en place ce numéro d'urgence
c'est une façon de dire aux jeunes
vous pouvez téléphoner et ensuite on va
s'occuper de vous et vous diriger vers
les bonnes personnes
le numéro d'urgence devrait être actif
d'ici la fin de l'année selon
l'observatoire de la vie étudiante 5%
les étudiants sont en situation de
précarité
hier c'est le haut-commissaire aux
retraites qui s'est rendu dans le
département jean paul delevoye était à
vélizy pour un débat sur la prochaine
réforme des retraites justement une
rencontre avec des citoyens pour
expliquer les prochaines modifications
du système actuel l occasion aussi de
récolter les interrogations et les
contradictions avec en ligne de mire
cette mobilisation interprofessionnelle
prévue le 5 décembre prochain contre le
projet nicolas landry faire de la
pédagogie autour de la prochaine réforme
l'objectif de cette réunion publique à
vélizy avec jean paul delevoye
haut-commissaire aux retraites
le nouveau système des retraites par
répartition sera universel et par point
avec la fin des 42 régimes spéciaux
d'autres principes sont encore en débat
quand on est dans l'universalité des
droits c'est les mêmes règles pour tous
un métier l'antique retraite identique
et tout ce qui ne justifie pas une
spécificité une particularité comme les
artisans les commerçants les professions
libérales ou les professions régaliennes
qui assurent notre sécurité
tout cela intégrera le régime universel
ça c'est un vrai débat vous savez entre
l'âge de déquilibre que j'ai proposé et
celles et ceux qui souhaiteraient une
durée de cotisation individuelle
c'est en cours de débat ceci sera
tranchée d'ici la fin d'année
près d'une centaine de personnes
présentes pour cette soirée ils ont pu
poser des questions ou interpeller le
haut commissaire sur leurs inquiétudes
je n'attends pas cette réforme je crains
cette réforme on est bien d'accord
cette réforme je n'en veux pas car c'est
une réforme qui sera au tour d'une
retraite à points
le groupe modem à l'assemblée nationale
appelle à l'organisation d'une
conférence sociale dans le parisien en
ligne de mire notamment éviter un
durcissement du conflit social à partir
du 5 décembre avec un appel à une grève
illimitée face à la réforme des
retraites
quand je crois que tout le monde est
convaincu de l'idée qu'il faut aller au
bout de la réforme de notre système de
retraite cela passe par du dialogue par
de la concertation il va y avoir le 5
décembre qui sera un moment d'expression
je souhaite que ça ne dégénère pas et
que ça ne devienne pas une expression de
violence mais que le dialogue domine sur
la violence et que nous puissions
collectivement porter cette réforme des
retraites en 2010 est la france comptait
près de 16,2 millions de retraités sur
la même année les dépenses allouées à ce
poste atteignent les 325 milliards
d'euros lutter contre l'antisémitisme à
travers l'art depuis hier le théâtre
montansier de versailles se rend dans
des lycées heavy noah pour lire des
textes d'albert cohen et de primo levi
au total plus de 2500 et lycéens sont
concernés par la démarche
mais annie poquet assister à l'une des
représentations ce matin à maurepas
enfants albert cohen publie ses mots en
1972 il relate une histoire son histoire
celle de ses 10 ans depuis le 18
novembre samir siad les lie à des lycées
pour sensibiliser à l'antisémitisme
on parle de lecture mais dans tous les
sens du terme et dire qu'à la fois une
lecture à voix haute
on fait passer les mots des auteurs mais
aussi une lecture dans le champ d'une
interprétation donc forcément et a
fortiori face à de tels textes on peut
pas rester indifférent
des lectures lancé par le théâtre
montansier une vingtaine de lycées lino
à l'accueil en novembre et en mars le
programme scolaire des lycéens faits qui
sont sensibilisés
avec tout ce qui s'est passé pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale etc
il aborde le sujet avec plus de notion
donc c'est plus facile de diriger
vers eux d'autant que ces textes sont
très porteurs à albert cohen se joue un
primo levi qui témoigne de sa survie à
auch 8 lecture d'une heure suivi d'un
échange entre jamais comédien c'était
très émouvant
on voit que certaines personnes peuvent
vraiment se reconnaître dans le rôle du
petit garçon ça m'a touché parce qu'on
retrouve vraiment le cours de dents en
fait c'est vraiment la même chose que ce
que le prof nous raconte c'est vraiment
une histoire sincère ça ça n'est ni
vraiment le racisme
on espère bien évidemment avoir
l'occasion par la suite de sensibiliser
les élèves à d'autres types de
discriminations et à faire en sorte que
le vivre ensemble se diffuse le mieux
possible
plus de 2500 élèves seront ainsi
sensibilisés sur ces deux périodes
d'intervention
après deux années de recul les actes
antisémites ont augmenté de 74% en 2018
à répondre aux besoins de logements
sociaux en zone rurale c'est le but du
pass rural au gie le département des
yvelines en a signé quatre
aujourd'hui avec des communes du pays où
danet deux attaques one year et les
autres à molette et à 70
ce sont en tout plus de 70 logements qui
seront réalisés suite à ces signatures
et via se passe les yvelines accompagne
financièrement les communes dans la
construction une enveloppe de 16
millions d'euros est dédié au projet une
expertise est également apportée via l'
agence d'ingénierie et par la mise en
relation des communes avec les bailleurs
sociaux
il s'alarme dans un hôpital public à
bout de souffle personnel soignant des
hôpitaux ont emmené une journée de
mobilisation jeudi dernier entre 7000 et
dix mille personnes ont par exemple
défilé est dans les rues de paris
edouard philippe doit faire demain à des
annonces pour mettre fin à la crise qui
a débuté en mars avec le mouvement au
sein des services d urgence on parle de
ce mouvement injustement des mouvements
qui se déroulent en ce moment avec
sébastien points
bonsoir françois de du syndicat
sud-santé 78 que vous dénoncez avant
tout c'est le manque d'effectif le
manque de moyens financiers
aujourd'hui c'est clairement les budgets
qui sont pas à la hauteur pour que les
hôpitaux publics puissent mener à bien
leur mission
de rendre service sur le guide donc
aujourd'hui on a un des budgets qui sont
limitées restrictif
les budgets des hôpitaux ou diminue
d'année en année et on ne peut pas
continuer dans cette logique financière
alors que le soin n'a pas de prix c'est
pas une marchandise
on soigne des gens on voit pas des
patates dans les supermarchés donc
donc oui il ya quelque chose à faire et
si on prend par exemple justement le cas
de l'hôpital andré mignot le centre
hospitalier andré mignot au chesnay
rocancourt où vous exercez quelles
conséquences a finalement ce manque de
moyens ce manque d'effectif
aujourd'hui c'est des vacataires qui
viennent combler les postes vacants mais
sans faire le travail des titulaires
puisque ben ils choisissent leur leurs
horaires ils choisissent le travail qui
est bien faire ils sont mieux payé qu'un
agent ou qui est titulaire et qu'il ya
20 ans d'ancienneté ce sont des rappels
pour les personnels des rappels à
domicile constamment enfin c'est une
pénurie de personnel d'agents mais dans
tous les secteurs que ce soit
administrative technique paramédicaux et
y compris les médecins qui s'en vont
dans le privé parce que sont largement
mieux payés donc il ya des crises de
profession chez les infirmiers
anesthésistes les infirmières de bloc
les manips radio les infirmières enfin
partout bien entendu dans les cortèges
le terme de mort lente finalement de
l'hôpital public vous êtes d'accord avec
félicien complètement ça c'est
complètement ça c'est à dire que depuis
les années mitterrand
en fait les aux piles et les grandes
entreprises françaises sont exonérés de
cotisations sociales c'est à dire ce que
appelle des charges
ils font du chantage à l'emploi depuis
plus de 30 ans et ils continuent de
licencier et pendant ce temps là
l'argent des cotisations sociales qu'ils
devraient payer ne va pas dans les
caisses de la protection sociale
donc pour 2018 et 2019 c'est plus de
entre 10 et 20 milliards de manque à
gagner pour la faim de manque à gagner
d'argent pour la sécurité sociale c'est
notre bien commun c'est pas l'argent des
patrons c'est le nôtre
un cortège à paris entre 7000 et 10000
personnes qui ont défilé il y avait
aussi des mobilisations dans les
yvelines est ce que la grève a été
suivie dans les yvelines justement jeudi
dernier dans les yvelines a été
massivement suivi je sais que sur poissy
rambouillet mende versailles
ça a été très suivie y compris sur
plaisir enfin tous les hôpitaux du
département il ya eu plusieurs centaines
voire plus de 1000 personnes des
yvelines qui était la manifestation
parisienne
et oui ça a été énormément suivi et on
voit ces images de nos confrères de 7,8
actu une opération à l'hôpital mignot ou
vous êtes allongé dont le hall d'accueil
qu'est ce que vous vouliez faire passer
comme message au travers de cette action
la mort dans l'hôpital c'est là qu'on
est en train de tuer l'hôpital public
comme on a tué les le social en france
comme en a tué la protection de
l'enfance en france en vendant sa au
privé est en fait ce que veut le
gouvernement c'est tout privatisé il l'a
fait avec la poste avec la sncf le
prochain la prochaine étape c'est là la
santé puis ce sera l'éducation nationale
en fait ce gouvernement ne voit que par
la privatisation à outrance le service
public on paie des impôts pour cela des
cotisations pour ça et ça sert à ça et
effectivement demain matin d'ailleurs le
personnel de l'hôpital mignot se donnera
rendez vous également à 10h45 de l'eau
donnant lieu au pardon de l'hôpital pour
refaire la même opération
et j'invite évidemment l'ensemble des
usagers qui souhaiteraient se joindre à
nous à nous rejoindre demain matin à
10h45 à l'hôpital mignot justement
demain emmanuel macron a fait savoir qu'
edouard philippe annoncerait des mesures
et des décisions fortes selon les termes
du président de la république à l'issue
du conseil des ministres est ce que vous
en attendez grand chose qu'est ce que
vous demandez finalement qu'est-ce que
vous attendez de sérieusement le
personnel hospitalier ce sont des moyens
donc du budget des augmentations de
salaires de nos salaires sont gelés
depuis dix ans c'est juste plus possible
de vivre aujourd'hui on survit les
agents demandent 300 euros minimum
d'augmentation et pas des primes de
l'augmentation
et puis on demande du personnel on
manque de personnel dans les hôpitaux on
est au service minimum tous les jours
c'est plus possible de continuer comme
ça enfin on a eu des vagues dessus ici
là depuis quelques années et on peut pas
continuer à travailler dans ces
conditions là c'est bien intenable
mais je le disais c'est un mouvement qui
a débuté avec le personnel des services
d'urgence en mars qui s'est tendu
finalement à l'ensemble des personnels
soignants c'est un mouvement qui
s'annonce long en tout cas vous vous me
n'arrêterai pas la mobilisation tant
qu'il n'y aura pas d'entrée pas entendu
non sens c'est clair les annonces de
demain enfin personnellement moi je
n'attends pas grand chose on va nous
faire un petit saupoudrage on va
certainement effacer une partie de la
dette mais sous quelles conditions et
comment on ne sait pas mais la dette des
hôpitaux elle est complètement
illégitime c'est la t2a en partie qui
nous a mis dedans aussi plus le manque
de moyens afin de ces exonérations de
cotisations dont je parlais tout à
l'heure
donc il faut revoir le système c'est pas
juste un petit saupoudrage qu'il faudra
il faut revoir le système et ce
qu'attendent les gens c'est des moyens
pour l'hôpital public c'est du personnel
et des augmentations de salaires s'il
n'y a pas ça c'est une vraie déception
les agents seront très déçu je pensais
que vous lisiez une mobilisation au
niveau local un qui est d'ores et déjà
prévue demain à l'hôpital mignot au
chesnay rocancourt merci sébastien point
d'être passé en plateau du syndicat
sud-santé 78 dans l'actualité également
une délégation internationale reçus hier
au ski cubes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des
représentants finlandais roumains et
estoniens sont venus sur place pour
parler cybersécurité cette journée
s'inscrit dans un cycle de trois jours
est dans la continuité de la part ici
berwick mais aussi du travail de
visibilité européenne engagée avec les
causses et l'européenne cyber security
organisation à la délégation
internationale a pu échanger avec divers
membres du ski club mais aussi avec des
start up occuper un cube est sur place
écoutez ses propos au micro de manon
varaldo la cybersécurité est quelque
chose que les personnes connaissent dont
ils ont de plus en plus conscience plus
que jamais et les compagnies sont plus
vulnérables sur ça
the company's donc les compagnies
offrent une protection quand elles
peuvent trouver de nouvelles solutions
pour mettre fin aux mauvais gars je
dirais c'est très important de
considérer que notre vue dépens les
enjeux liés à la cybersécurité
aujourd'hui tout est digital donc si
vous n'avez pas ti ver sécurité
concrètement il n'y a pas de confiance
il n'y a pas d'usagers donc ya pas de
développement ni économique ni sociale à
la délégation a poursuivi sa journée
hier avec la visite de silicone à
guyancourt et des locaux d'atos aux
clayes-sous-bois au chapitre des
élections municipales de 2001 la liste
d'opposition réinventons elancourt vient
de lancer officiellement sa campagne
pour le scrutin programmé en mars
prochain une candidature de gauche qui
se veut participative et qui présentait
samedi dernier sa tête de liste les
détails dorés les onze c'est elle qui
conduira la liste et réinventant
elancourt aux prochaines élections
municipales élan courtoise depuis plus
de 30 ans catherine perron temps raufast
et médecins le collectif qui l'a désigné
est composé de militants politiques
associatifs et de citoyen elancourt que
j'aime beaucoup c'est ma ville a
beaucoup changé et l'encours est devenue
une ville morne endormi où il ne se
passe plus rien
pour moi je pense qu'il faut vraiment
que les habitants puissent reprendre en
main lors gilles réinventons et
l'encours est une liste participatif qui
défend des valeurs de gauche
pour cette nouvelle réunion près de 80
personnes avaient fait le déplacement à
la maison de quartier de la ville dieu
c'est l'avenir c'est ce que les gens
recherchent en ce moment ils en ont
marre des prises de décisions
centralisée donc ils ont besoin d'avoir
un tracteur de leur propre destin et de
leurs décisions
donc c'est l'intérêt de ces listes que
tout le monde puisse y trouver son
compte et avoir un vrai intérêt à y
participer
je suis dans les jardins familiaux des
quatre arbres qui sont menacées de
destruction depuis plusieurs années par
la mairie et là j'ai trouvé une liste
qui s'engagent à les préserver et même à
les agrandir
donc c'était la raison du pourquoi je
suis venu cet après midi même si le
programme est encore en cours
d'élaboration les principaux comptes
étaient présentés lors de cette réunion
tous nos axes c'est démocratie
participative transition écologique est
une ville pour tous les âges pour tous
les quartiers pour tous les besoins
autre projet évoqué l'aménagement de la
colline d'elancourt dans une perspective
verte ou encore une gestion raisonnée eu
son temps en fin de mandat les
représentants du code est ce qu'ils se
sont réunis une dernière fois samedi
dernier le conseil de développement de
saint quentin en yvelines se questionner
ces dernières années sur la thématique
de la jeunesse le reportage de marie
lehn iapichino depuis 2002 l'institution
consultative de l'agglomération le codis
qui mène l'enquêté auprès des habitants
et restitue son travail aux élus
dernière réunion avant le prochain
mandat pour ses 96 membres le thème la
jeunesse
je pense pas que les plus vieux apporte
des réponses aux plus jeunes
je pense que tout procède d'un véritable
dialogue est ce qu'à fait de coder ce
qui remarquable c'est cette possibilité
d'un dialogue entre des jeunes et des
moins jeunes ou entre des jeunes et des
institutions saint quentin en yvelines a
besoin d'attirer les jeunes
la tranche d'âge 18 30 ans manquent
or ces jeunes actifs sont nécessaires
pour les entreprises du territoire
le codis qui a mené une large enquête
auprès d'eux et l'a présentée avec des
tables rondes sur trois grands axes les
transports le logement et les loisirs
c'était très intéressant c'est qu'on a à
la fois des positions d'élus donc en
responsabilité car la capacité de faire
advenir des choses et puis des échanges
des acteurs de terrain qui ont
l'expérience du vécu des jeunes ou de
leur vécu que deux acteurs qui animent
le territoire l'occasion aussi de
dresser un bilan pour son président
après ses trois années de travaux et
réunion je trouve qu'on pourrait
remettre un peu à une autre place le coc
des skis qui n'est qu'une instance
participative et il n'est pas question
de prendre la place des élus mais bon
parfois un petit regret de ne pas être
entendus à la hauteur de 2 des travaux
qui sont effectués mais globalement
c'est vraiment une bonne expérience se
connaissent qui prendra fin en même
temps que les mandats municipaux
ses membres espèrent alors qu'il sera
renouvelée rapidement après les
élections du mois de mars
[Musique]
là je reçois présents sur ce plateau
jean michel2 le teint bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le responsable dans les
yvelines de l'association bouchons
d'amour alors elle oeuvre dans la france
entière et aussi en ile de france avec 8
équipes départementales première de vos
missions
bien sûr c'est la collecte de bouchons
pour pour aider les personnes en
situation de handicap sans aucun
problème
ça fait partie de la création
d'entreprise qui était de l'association
qui a été fait par jean marie bigard en
2001 qui à terme modifier le nom en 2005
par le bouchon d'amour et c'est le
principal but c'est de collecter tous
les bouchons qui sont revendus à une
société de recyclage et avec cet argent
tout l'intégrale l'intégralité de cette
somme d'argent et reversés au bénéfice
des personnes handicapées par les jean
marie bigard qui aujourd'hui le parrain
de cette association toujours été le
parrain de l'association puisque c'est
lui qui l'a créé alors vous vous rendez
vous l'avez dit ces bouchons un
partenaire aussi clair qu'est ce qui est
acheté ensuite quel matériel est acheté
pour ces personnes en situation de
handicap est justement de matériel qui
peut aider une personne handicapée c'est
que ça va les aider à acheter un
fauteuil que de l'aménagement d'une
cuisine
l'aménagement de monte escalier
l'aménagement même d'appareils auditifs
tout ce qui peut aider une personne
handicapée et vous aider
particulièrement deux associations c'est
ça on est de 2 à sion 2 association
nationale qui est l'association
handi'chiens qui éduque des chiens
d'assistance pour les personnes
handicapées par des chiens aveugles mais
on aide aussi l'association la
fédération française handisport pour que
les petits clubs puissent acquérir du
matériel et on précise que l'association
bouchons d'amour est reconnue d'intérêt
général d'intérêt général alors pourquoi
alors la question s'adresse à vous mais
aussi aux bénévoles qui s'engagent au
sein de bouchons d'amour pourquoi cet
engagement pour les personnes en
situation de handicap et est important
je vous pose alors la question à vous
pourquoi il est important à vos yeux
parce que je vais commencer je vais
commencer tout doucement en 2001 à
collecter des bouchons et puis ça m'a
permis de rencontrer beaucoup de
personnes handicapées de m'apercevoir
que cb j'en avais besoin
outre du matériel d'avoir aussi des dz
et de des dialogues de j'ai toujours
pensé que moi la solitude était la plus
grave des maladies qu'on voulait avoir
alors vous êtes je n'ai pas précisé
trésorier de l'association au niveau
régional président des bouchons d'amour
78 à puisque l'association est divisé en
ile-de-france en huit équipes
départementales l'île de france grâce à
une équipe en principe par l'esrb pape
noir 17 départements et paris en
fonction des bénévoles qui peut y avoir
parce que bien entendu comme toute
association on recherche des bénévoles
pour venir nous aider ça c'est oui l
inde et l actualité actualité
tous les jours c'est la recherche de
bénévoles à la charge de collecter des
bouchons
c'est simple les années un autre endroit
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué et
après faire le tri presque c'est vrai on
s'aperçoit que les gens n'ont pas
forcément le bon réflexe vont mettre les
bons bouchon à l'intérieur donc un objet
de faire le tri des scuds ses récents
ses difficultés de trouver des bénévoles
ou ça a toujours existé
je pense qu'il n'y a pas que les
bouchons d'amour je pense que c'est un
petit peu national de trouver des
bénévoles et de trouver des gens motivés
une crise une crise de la vocation de
crise du bénévolat peut être
actuellement
ça fait longtemps que c'est
et ça existe dans les yvelines bouchons
d'amour que vous êtes implanté dans les
yvelines les bouchons d'amour j'ai créé
l'association les bouchons d'amour 78 en
2013 grâce à la société accès aux qui
fait de l'aide à la personne
on a pu avoir un petit local qui a
permis de commencer et après grâce à la
mairie de mantes la ville qui a accepté
de mettre un local beaucoup plus
importants pour stocker les bouchons
seront là on a peut continuer sans ses
deux aides on n'existerait pas vous êtes
parti d'un local mais aujourd'hui vous
avez plusieurs points de de stockage
dont une dans les yvelines de collecte
dans les toilettes on a beaucoup de
points de collecte qui sont sur le sur
le site que les gens peuvent rechercher
pour trouver la facilité que s'affiche à
quel point la facilité pour eux et après
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué seller
de ce drôle deux endroits de stockage
que l'on là c'est uniquement à mantes la
ville
c'est la seule commune des yvelines qui
a mis un local à notre disposition
donc on a un grand local où on peut on
peut mettre tous les sacs qui sont rivés
et on a un petit local où là c'est les
écrits et ses il ya l'électricité le
chauffage et toilettes où on peut faire
tranquillement le tri sens sans se geler
on vous parlait de thor des bénévoles
votre équipe dans les yvelines
combien de bénévoles sont engagés au
sein des bouchons d'amour on est quand
même très nombreux on doit être six ou
sept
donc oui c'est d'où l'importance vous le
dit tout à l'heure de trouver de
nouveaux bénévoles
alors on peut et des bouchons d'amour on
imagine en rejoignant l'association
devenant bénévole mais il ya plusieurs
moyens d'aider votre association qui a
tous les moyens d'abord c'est en créant
des points de collecte chez soi après on
pourra s'asseoir son environnement c'est
sa famille les voisins
donc on récupère tout ça prend on
retransmet ses bouchons dans une
dans un point de collecte un petit peu
plus important soit une grande surface
où un commerçant soit après il ya des
entreprises qui collectent aussi les
bouchons
j'ai la chance d'avoir fort-de-france
qui est qui était à saint germain en
laye dans le ciel est à saint germain
qui m'a prêté une camionnette à peu près
deux fois par an pendant plusieurs jours
entièrement gracieusement donc ça me
permettait d'aller chercher des bouchons
et de les transmettre
je crois qu'il est possible le terme de
devenir bigarchons collector on parlait
de tout ailleurs jean marie bigard qui
est le parrain se dire qu'on peut
collecter nous mêmes des bouchons au
sein de son entreprise au sein
l'association son club absolument tout
et tout est possible de collecter les
entreprises me contactent des
établissements choléra scolaire me
contacter aussi donc je vais aller à
leur rencontre leur expliquons fait de
la quoi ça sert et pourquoi ça sert donc
en règle générale des enfants sont très
très intéressé pour ça parce qu'ils ont
une possibilité au moins quand ils
veulent pape allemand man jeté une
bouteille avec le bouchon leur faire
gentiment leur maman à tailler ses
bouchons et pour une fois qu'ils ont un
petit peu d'autorité sur les parents
tout se passe bien et dans les
entreprises il n'y a pas de soucis
j'étais fière sagemcom à oreille
malmaison pour présenter l'association
qui vont comme épaissi vont mettre en
place de la collecte des bouchons
il n'y a pas de souci particulier pour
ceux qui veulent créer quelque chose on
est toujours à leur disposition et pour
aider l'association à voir aussi plus
d'informations à deux sites internet le
site au national de bouchons et d'amour
mais aussi le site sur l'île de france 1
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran pour
avoir toutes les informations notamment
à connaître lé point de collecte merci
jean michel de llotes d'être passé en
plateau un autre je rappelle que vous
êtes le président de bouchons d'amour 78
je vous remercie à mon tour cette
réalisation pour refermer ce journal un
pinocchio et son jiminy cricket en pâte
à sucre
grâce à cette oeuvre sur mesure la clé
sienne noah batum a remporté la médaille
de bronze au dernier concours
international de cake design c'était
être démis le début d'un début novembre
je vais y arriver à birmingham en
angleterre le cake design s'est réalisé
des gâteaux sur mesure et très créatif
et noah batum n'en est pas à son coup
d'essai elle réalise diverses créations
avait empoché l'an passé est la médaille
d'argent au même événement en 2018 elle
avait obtenu la médaille de bronze au
paris-sg sugar 2018 voilà c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
dans quelques instants toutes les idées
de sorties culturelles à retrouver dans
l'émission 7 8 culture avec aurélie
ronde belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]